hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play don't
starve okay when we left off we were
starving and going insane so we got to
do a lot really quickly to try to
alleviate the situation because we just
came out of the night and we're not
doing very good so but we didn't die a
lot of people were very surprised at I
did not die my first night so I say haha
I am too bro and someone said that you
can use the the WASD keys to move and
space to interact with your environment
so I'm gonna use that to try to make it
a little easier to move around I need to
get wood and stones to build another
fire because I'm gonna be moving can I
eat pine cones why can I not seems like
that would have more manu trician than
some frickin leaves okay anyway but I'm
not gonna complain because I am a
professional a professional starvation
expert okay
some stones was this just a ruddy old
tree there nothing good to it come on I
need one I need something to eat because
I am NOT gonna make it through my next
night if I can't get food where is the
the seeds off thank goodness some seats
okay eat those right away I don't have
enough to make a farm so I just got to
eat everything that I find did I pick up
my I didn't okay what is this box
thing huh alright is that an egg oh my
goodness ha-ah
can I eat that would it be bad for me
yeah yeah yeah you'll think that you can
get me I have your egg get away are you
so stupid I'm going to lose you in the
rocks no I'm not apparently anyway I'm
getting closer to back where I started
let me pick a flower here give it the
job go for the eyes I hit it oh it was
attacking it no turn that off you can't
hit me
aha who's the winner now ah God hit me
oh now I'm gonna die
you'll take me down alright screw this
this is not going to go well I I can't
do this I'm almost dead ha ha I was a
bad choice he's gonna eat your egg no
I'm numb numb wait hang on num-num
num-num-num
hey what you gonna do now you can do no
i'll there's a berry bush
num num num num num num num I'm not
eating it I don't have enough time cuz I
can't get away from this guy he's really
persistent I'm guessing this is a tall
bird which makes total sense cuz it's a
very tall bird oh here's a bridge into
another area it is not alright you know
what this isn't worth it take your
stupid egg take your take your stupid
egg I don't want it anymore go away
please
go I I think it's now angry because I
hit it fine you know what I'm gonna take
your bird egg and I'm gonna be ah ha ha
no no I anyway it doesn't matter because
I wasn't doing that good anyway so now
that we officially died everyone happy
now markiplier officially died and don't
starve but I didn't starve to death
cuz I accidentally picked up up yeah
yeah yeah good dude - alright so anyway
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna get stuff
right away leaves or something there's
some seeds down there my hand
get that get these seeds there rake this
what is that a spider den I don't I'm
not gonna need that well I gotta go near
could to get those berries what was that
what the hell is that
what do I dunno that a turkey America on
it eat yeah hey what's with all the
turkeys never seen these turkeys before
in my life
I need an axe so let's make up a axe
real quick
BAM I'm gonna chop the hell out of those
turkeys for that log I need stones
come here little buddy Turner father
quick how do I get them I just got to
get him in a corner right you can't run
from me I will get you I will get you I
ran you away from your hole I'm catching
up I've got the gap packet I'm ending
space target got it no fine
I'll just get the berries there's plenty
of berries around here so I don't really
need any to get that carrot then make
once I make a trap for the bunnies I
don't have time I don't have time
lots of saplings lots of sticks plus a
flint or the turkeys in the corner if I
can get it maybe I can get it maybe we
can get it going away all right I can't
quite get it Harriet hooked up but okay
I need wood OOP OOP come on keep
chopping I don't know if I'm supposed to
like hold down or click just once
everyone so long yeah yeah yeah take
that nature I'm such a badass it's
amazing I just come into this place and
I suddenly I'm an eco-terrorist and mass
murderer Burt Burt got a survive one way
or another he'll well it'll men and
someone said that picking up flowers
increases your sanity so I'm gonna
definitely focus on that okay so I got a
lot of goodies here but not enough stone
to make a fire pit for my first night
which is definitely what I need you know
I'm not gonna use space because I don't
like to space I like to actually click
on things WASD to move around but
definitely clicking on things to do
stuff also I really like the music in
this game I gotta say I mean I always
loved this this type of style music I
don't even know what style music is
because I'm not a big listener music ah
look at the flowers they make me less
same or more sane less insane more sane
alright plenty of saplings enough to
make up kick axe but I haven't seen any
stones around here
don't know what's going on with that I
need I need like giant rocks Eman oh
come on
I need something need something need
something need something what's on the
ground over there what is this blue
mushroom it's sleeping what are you
talking about if it comes out at night
uh no no there's another rabbit but I
can't get you hang on I'm gonna get it
okay got a trap here and then I got a
carrot so if I put the trap down here
and put a carrot in front of it maybe
that maybe I can chase that rabbit
oh no the rabbit holes right there look
at that it's moving towards it oh we're
moving towards it get it get it
you tell you I do don't you want a
carrot it's a delicious delectable
little treat it's you to get it I will
get a rabbit to eat tonight
come on a pronoun oh I can't make a fire
oh no what happened all my grass ah well
I can't make a fire pit but I can
definitely make a campfire Yeah right
whatever fine good enough
let me just chop a few more trees to get
enough wood to last me through the night
I got enough wood left me all night long
ding ding convicted okay Oh worry about
that trap tomorrow the rabbit holes
right nearby so it shouldn't it
shouldn't be too much of a problem to
get the guy to go to there and get the
gone and I've got plenty of food
surprisingly lots of berries and seeds
we're gonna be okay maybe I don't know
it's almost night but not quite so we're
fine just gather what we can pick up
lower raise your sanity mmm
I feel so much better now can I plant
flowers no they turned into flower
petals alrighty see toss if you just few
things on the fire oh good not in
sameness can I move that trap closer to
you because I bet that rabbit won't come
out if I'm like right next to it so let
me pick that up and put this like right
on top of the tree I put that right on
top of the rabbit hole and then put that
right there how do I only drop one I
only want to drop one and I pick this up
that's two closest I don't know I'm
probably doing it wrong like usual just
gathering stuff more berries berries
grass eat the berries cuz we need to eat
something
oh those yeah that'll do it mmm okay
it's all right it's all right how do I
only drop one maybe if I Shh shift-click
snow let's drop some all right click no
that drop
ahh that dropped one okay that planet it
got it you got to right-click the plant
got it so I'm just circling my
encampment with plants here
hopefully they'll grow in a few days
apparently you got to play through this
game like months and months and months
to do anything relevant so probably in
between this episode and the next
episode there'll be a bit of a time jump
as I coordinate myself oh it's night Oh
gali gali gali gali gali gali gali gali
and what I'll do when it hits night I'm
just gonna sit here and wait and I'll
accelerate through time so you guys
don't have to don't have to sit and wait
through the night because nothing
happens at night right
think fine Oh a murder perhaps no caught
fire don't set fire to my trap please I
would rather not have that happen all
right
oh I can make a torch maybe I can that
way I can explore in the night we look
at me go oh that's not very much light
and some anyway huh here's a boulder I
could just uh uh nothing I could see you
again
no kidding all right I'm just gonna
accelerate through the night and you
guys will see me in the morning okay it
is now morning and Wow that bird is
close to me ah I'd ran away okay that
blue mushroom is there hopefully um I
don't know how to put I'm gonna let that
just burn out because I want that rabbit
eventually come out of that rabbit hole
and get caught in the trap
hopefully things carry on when I'm not
nearby so if I'm not near it'll still
come out anyway I'm gonna mine stuff
because I need to get a science machine
up and going Nader Flint so I need to
find a lot more of rocks and stiff where
can I find rocks and stuff I definitely
need more food so I'm hoping hoping that
if I oh wait I know how to drop one now
so I'm gonna pick up that carrot so that
I can you make another trap because I've
got two carrots down there yeah let me
just pick up the trap anyway because
that doesn't look like anything's
happening there hey my trees are growing
look at that oh man this is exciting but
so exciting
I'm the best I'm the best there ever was
I'm gonna pick a lot more grass so I can
make more traps as need be I see some
rabbit holes here but no rabbits I just
got to get him before they get scared
off in the night Rach this is Bo's Oh
okay sit down the trap put that right
down here I'm gonna set one here by it
herb oh I can't drop okay just right
yeah it's okay
perfectly okay mr. rabbit perfectly okay
go get it go go get it nice not coming
you're not gonna be scared are you I'll
go over here you won't be scared
right right it just it seems suspicious
but it's not it's totally okay Oh ah
don't get away from I Karen no no aah oh
yeah I got a rabbit murder grrrrrr I did
it
our main meat yes
and there's another rabbit over there
but I don't have carrots but I can chase
it into the trap I now know this if I
can get it away from its hole I'll set
the trap down here and then I'll swing
up north and chase it away from his hole
but there's a rat suit oh I'm wearing
the grass suit come here nope nope nope
nope you're gonna go to the lab yeah
yeah yep no not quite almost almost got
that run away haha oh come on oh right
there
no raba there's lots of all carrot
carrot carrot carrot carrot perfect
perfect perfect
carrot carrot come here come here carrot
I'm running out of daylight I need more
I need more wood ah piss dammit I was
hoping to get more rabbit today but it
doesn't look like I'm gonna have enough
time let me try to and if I put the
carrot on the right and get that one to
come over yeah come on he's gonna walk
right into the trap hopefully Oh hold on
des hold on daylight bird get away
you're distracting the rabbit from the
trap gonna get it it's gonna get it it's
gonna get it it's gonna get it it's
gonna get it oh oh oh oh I'm gonna have
to rabbit run away yeah yeah hope you
enjoyed that where else
yes yes hey it's survival Hey
it's all that matters I'm gonna look at
this skeleton find my old body actually
that probably is my old no that can't be
my old buy is a new world okay anyway so
I got these here I don't have enough
time to get another one there alone
you're gonna run into their holes what I
need is to make some more wood chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop
ham I can't even see to it can't even
see to it alright fine damn fire right
by all these lovely rabbit holes that's
someone to that that's good enough
nice and bright I'm gonna need another
axe real soon
chop chop get that rope chop chop chop
chop and then I will cook up these
lovely rabbits and eat them nah I mean
um
lots of logs pine cones I'll check up
north my other trees why I guess I don't
really need to check on him I got plenty
of trees down here I don't there's no
explicit need that I would have to have
that I didn't get enough gold to make um
anything like that I think you just
cooked yeah
Boosh cookie cookie mmm
et nom nom oh that's not nearly enough
food oh I thought that was gonna be so
much more I'm gonna need to get like
lots of rabbits now it's raining that's
gonna do a wonder on my psyche whatever
whatever just get wood I haven't seen
any berry bushes either like they were
all a bunch of berry bushes up north and
then those perky's I don't think my trap
can catch a turkey I don't know I'd love
to get a turkey don't know where to get
those but now it's 9 3 REE and raining
I'm have to eat my petals
to get something there we go okay got
plenty of wood now I guess we get that
sapling why not now jump pick up these
pine guns for later anyone have more
fuel to the fire BuChE BuChE nice and
warm 80s I guess for something it's
something you know actually that doesn't
do anything they literally do nothing
from anger if anything they're making me
more hungry
all right seeds will work though there
we go little bit from the seed ah seeds
up here - mmm so delicious
could I have cooked the seeds I've no
idea can I cook the pedals no just cure
wash wash remembered I don't think I can
get the birds in the trans-canada I
wouldn't know how lorem with seeds I ate
all my seeds no anyway it's getting
night so we're gonna accelerate through
the night soon so just hold onto your
giblets I'm gonna starve but we're gonna
be okay my grass suit is gonna catch on
fire seeds look at these birds next time
did you wait everybody just you wait
good morning everybody all right well
I've set up a few things here um we got
uh I got a line of traps since there are
so many rabbit holes around here I'm
just gonna assume that I can eventually
get them all in one and what I'm gonna
do is I'm also gonna play some seeds by
these traps
so hopefully oh babe oh well done which
I did known that you click directly on
the trip you probably we're all like oh
you're gonna do banned Marga are we
doing okay anyway I baited those with
seeds hopefully they'll catch a rabbit
or something I got a lot of them there
anyway I need to there we go there's
what I'm looking for I need gold cuz I
need to get my thing going because if I
can get seeds
no no gold no gold need gold need one of
those rocks with gold animal oh well
what I'll figure it out or I'll die
trying
most likely I'll die but who can fairies
but berries eat them rabbits where all
the rabbits doing down here I need them
up yonder way hmm
rabbits there's so many rabbits I was
actually close to that one uh I will
just dry Oh
run rabbit run run run run run run run
run run and run towards my traps
Roger do I dropped look good yo note
south south south tough north north
north yeah I got ya
okay flips her lid
cook it eat it mmm no me no me hi bird
ah ah I guess I have to be near them for
them to have any sort of effect no get
away
oh look at that you're gonna be chased
down nope
chase down chase down another trap yes
they just ate my seeds and didn't get
put in a trap damn it oh well I got
rabbits anyway hmm I'm still not eating
good I'm I'm still kind of starving
these
rabbits don't add enough there's plenty
of rabbits so gotta get him I wove it
real time
oh come here rabbit come in our I gotta
get gold though cuz I what I don't have
is materials nothing in that trap I know
that
alright alright alright alright alright
my cooking fire is now out well I worry
about that later
no all right whatever I got him I gotta
get gold because I got because I kind
just make a farm then I won't have to
worry about getting any more Oh carry
too much stuff cuz I just gotta eat this
alright whatever we just got to carry on
and not panic we're doing okay in terms
of food so as we forage or out forage
out we should be able to be okay on it I
don't know I don't know how we're gonna
do probably not well what we're gonna
try I'm just gonna drop a trapper cuz I
don't need that many
boop-boop-boop okay we need to find gold
berries get rid of - plenty bears okay
this is gonna help this will help this
will help a lot actually I'm guessing
foraging at this point is gonna be more
beneficial to me than trying to catch
animals because there's plenty of stuff
to forward around here like plenty of
that eat these carrots up oh I am full
on health why didn't I do that sooner
what kind of idiot am i trying to catch
rabbits when there's plenty of
blueberries around and I bet I find a
goldmine just soon here there the rock
hopefully that'll have some gold in it
and there's another berries so there's
plenty of food out in the fields no gold
no no gold
rocks plenty but no gold a mirror oh
come on how is it already almost evening
I'm so bad at this game what do you
expect this my second time playing
I'm talking to myself I'm already going
crazy I'm talking to myself here
actually now that I'm realizing in the
999 videos I've made I do nothing but
talk to myself like if anyone actually
hears me I must sound pretty insane to
be day after day just talk to myself
like her dear burger making strange
noises going around I really am going
crazy
I would guess people think that I really
am going crazy okay so I am actually all
out of time I find myself playing these
games more than I thought I would I'm
not gonna make a fire pit there's no
point cuz I'm not making a permanent
base I'm just moving from place to place
and then I'm shoving things in my face
like food and groove anyway so I'm gonna
cut it here just because there's nothing
really happens this late at night so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos if I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
ma
Oh